hey guys welcome back to a brand new
video Rebecca on foreign again today
we're gonna be talking about some
interesting info such as the new event
teacher that came out what the name is
and what it might possibly entail an
awesome passionate that's going to be
coming out at the release of that event
as well as the content of the week so I
just like to be if you do enjoy
subscribe for new I cover the
informational side of the 4runner that
being bounced changes here are updates
passionates and leaks so your honor we
kept those today with everything
happening in the world of foreigner and
not miss an update if we stay subscribe
to the channel and with that let's get
started with today's video so first up
let's talk about patch notes so first is
that they've talked about a few things
of what might be coming in next week's
patch and one of them is that there's
going to be a new tab in the
customization side where the masks are
going to be changed and it's gonna be
called the illustrious tab so I'm
thinking this has to do with a specific
thing we'll talk about later in the
video but that is gonna be a new thing
the mask tab will now be called the
illustrious tab they also decided about
removing revenge gained in 1v1 scenarios
that should be going live next week of
course if you're in a 1v1 I don't know
if it's where you earn no revenge at all
or you only earn to a certain threshold
and then once the second player comes in
you break that threshold I didn't
actually hear that part so I do
apologize a few other cool things is
that there might be a possibility that
story mode might be possible in arcade
for example meaning that this story mode
scenes could possibly be in arcade like
for example in the one story mode
mission you were battling a few enemies
on top of ice whole it was following
beneath you then that ended up becoming
a game we'll call ice brawlers they
could be using that type of element for
arcade or something like that so I think
that'd be really cool it's nothing too
crazy but I think just small details
like that would be really nice there's
also some talk about fixing up the
follow-up attacks when throwing an
opponent because sometimes when you
throw an attack it doesn't actually land
so they might actually end up fixing
this and this could also end up
affecting the out of stamina punishes so
that's nice to know
so definitely go check that out once
that goes live next week should nobody
slide tackle is gonna be nerfed it will
be hit at 600 milliseconds instead of
300 very similar to warlords crashing
charge but as a buff and kind of a
counterbalance Shinobi's third hit and
his own attack will finally be faint
ableism next week so it's been over a
year probably two years so finally
shinobi will be able to feign his own
Jane June is also gonna be saving a
couple nerfs in this next week patch
he's not gonna be having any armor on
the chokehold meaning Hickey can be
knocked out of a very similar to the
demons embrace that she goki has and
takes actual damage and not that
external stuff where your damage does 8
instead of 30 this is stuff like that
that's gonna be a pretty hefty nerf and
JJ's soothing mist has had a huge
significant nerf along way less health
for him and his teammates I don't
actually remember these specific numbers
but it all depends on how many players
or enemy players are near you so for
example the old buff used to be if there
were four opponents near you you would
get 85 health but that is not enough the
case you actually get 25 so that's the
most amount of health you can get from
the soothing mist buff into other
tidbits of info is that banner feats
will now stay on the field if your
person dies this was very similar to
what traps do if you do die and you have
a trap up and hasn't been activated it
will stay on the map but for banners
that wasn't the case so now they're
gonna make it so that banners do that
and the ballista will now not do 60
damage to the RAM it does 20 because
some people would camp the ballista and
shoot the RAM the whole time so they're
gonna try to make people not do that as
much beginning into the actual info and
the really important info today we have
a new event coming March 14th as we
stated last week and it's gonna be
called the black pyres or post and it
has a bird on the image I'll show the
image on the screen now they hinted
saying maybe some other things in the
image might be worth noting so the bird
is what I'm thinking is gonna be worth
noting since it's in the foreground and
everything else in the background is
pretty blurred and you can't see it this
also goes back to the illustrious tab
why is the mask tab being called the
illustrious tab at the same exact time
this event is coming out and why did
they tell us to look for to look around
for the image and some other stuff like
that so I'm thinking this has to do with
the bird we may get some emotes who
might get an outfit with the bird I have
no actual clue what this is but either
way I still think it's very interesting
that we're gonna be getting something
very new in the MassDEP coming next week
you have let me know you guys thoughts
on that I personally do think that we're
gonna be getting some type of bird
outfit I have no clue though but let me
know you guys think in the comments
below
and to end the video we have the newest
content of the week which is everybody's
second favorite type of content the
elite outfits it's gonna be the Falcons
reach for the Knights the tree out of
crows for the Vikings the lucky
for the samurai any Fortune spirit for
the woman snuffly go grab that if you
guys want to see that I'll show it up on
screen now that guy's gonna be the end
of the video hopefully you guys did
enjoy like the video if you did let me
know your thoughts on the new event in
the comments below what you guys think
of it what you guys think it's going to
be I'm very excited to hear what you
guys think and what that elective if you
do enjoy subscribe for new I cover the
informational site a foreigner that
being bounced changes here updates
patrons and leaks under be kept up to
date with everything happening in the
world of foreigner definitely stay
subscribe to the channel hi guys my two
most recent videos will be on screen if
you guys want to check that out I got so
burgers today for us the video and peace
out
[Music]